freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
heute eine kleine besonderheit ich koche
für zwei personen direkt und zwar toni
und mehr von ihr
das wird aber dementsprechend ein
bisschen aufwendiger heute deshalb legen
wir direkt los und zwar auf drei
verschiedene sachen nämlich smashed
avocado brett dazu zähle mit porridge
oder auch harfe weiter abnimmt und eines
mobilen pflege mal los indem ich hier
einen apfel schälen
wenn wie so oft schon ein bisschen spät
dran wir haben es mit einer nur wir
haben den apfel den strom raus
woher stellte zwei töpfe auf eine mit
wasser für pochiertes ei mit milch
ersatz für die fahrer von den appell
schneidet in scheibchen ich freue mich
heute besonders auch das mittagessen
nicht weiß schon was es gibt ihr müsst
ihr noch ein bisschen gedulden
es würden nämlich etwas exotisches so
viel kann ich schon mal sagen doch diese
geschnitten als nächstes schneiden wäre
eine avocado ich hab getröte leute
wirklich versteht weil der kader aus
leute also ich würde mir nur drei
avantgarde viertel pürieren und wird 1
dieses hier im kleine würfelchen
schneiden damit ich für die textur noch
ein bisschen etwas habe was nicht so
super training ist natürlich das
zusammen bei treffern ein paar
cherrytomaten halbiere ich einfach nur
als darsteller zur seite
dh wir gehen wir nicht einfach nach
gefühl
die saugen natürlich noch freundlich mit
auf dementsprechend müssen wir es nicht
so voll machen lieber nach krieg noch
ein bisschen mehr dafür geben würde ich
bereite schon mal den mixa vor
ganz ähnlich wie bei lukas siebenkotten
wäre mega lecker mega einfach das heißt
eine flex frühstück wieder weiß besteht
aus super viele komponenten aber ihr
seht ja super einfache handgriffe bevor
ich es nur die bälle schneidig aber eben
auch das brot entscheiden
ich habe hier vier große scheiben brot
geschnitten das sollte auch reichen und
es riecht so lecker mäandern kritik wir
trippeln unser olivenöl tour natürlich
wieder von beiden seiten und geben es
jetzt in den backofen zum anlass so
sieht das ganze übrigens jetzt auch
schön weg flüssig aber kostenlos sehr
flachen und dazugeben jetzt die
apfelstückchen dazu nach räumlichen und
zählt höre mir leute dahin hintergrund
sind schon alle angekommen und ich
musste hier sind nicht nur die baukammer
ich habe da drin gefrorenem anke und
himberg dazu bekommt jetzt mandeln nuss
drei teelöffel und man die milch ein
schuss essig in das wasser drehen wir
das ganze und geben die eier arbeiter
die angerosteten scheiben brot aus dem
ofen nehmen wir
hallo karo die hier auf jeden fall vier
prozent machten die anderen
nach einem soll das sind die passierten
nehmen wir jetzt also aus dem wasser
nehmen sie hier auch die tomaten noch
schnell ist nun wie baue ich und was
passt das sind die drei gerichte und die
serviere ich jetzt auf der terrasse
[Musik]
okay lasst euch schmecken für mich wie
urlaub ich meine sie kann man außen dann
sehen wir uns gleich zur bewertung
zweite runde leute in satz du gibst mir
einen ktm die jungs haben mich genötigt
ihn zu filmen würden dafür sehr gute
häufig so leute werden auf gelesen ich
hoffe wir sind nicht zu überbelichtet
wir haben nämlich so ein schönes wetter
dass das erste mal tatsächlich dass ich
auf dem balkon gegessen habe mehr als
gut geschmeckt was sagt ihr müsst euch
ja quasi noch beraten eigentlich nur
weil die kunst eine note wir können nur
eine zusammen
ich habe ganz kurz damit ihr das auch
mal checke ich habe vorher meinte
natürlich die hochgesteckten regierung
jetzt mal ganz ruhig sagen wir dann
wirklich ganz ganz resort wirklich hart
direkt gesagt so macht ganz ehrlich so
wirklich komplett ehrlich so mies
gefühlt hat okay hier nicht fangen wir
mit der smoothie die förmlich also so
wie ich es erwartet habe der mir so vor
geschäft ist so ein richtig schönes nur
die wohl wenn ich irgendwo einen
supertollen restaurant bestellen würde
und ich habe das gebrochen und gerissen
ich fand die kombination mit diesen
erfüllen und im zimt zwar nicht schön
der avocado brodmann das ding
ich habe ihm gesagt ich esse eigentlich
das ist am allerliebsten ja ich habe
schon viel
wurzeln mit avocado und ein gästen und
ich habe eben schon gesagt das hat mich
wieder nach amsterdam versetzt zu
unserem lieblings frühstücks laden das
heißt riehl
ich fand es von vorne bis hinten
richtigkeit ihrer zeit darf was denkst
du ich fand sich franz ja auch sehr
lecker auch das poly schweigen wieso
nimmt dich irgendwie ist fasten zur
jahreszeit auch jetzt bald weihnachten
so es ist essen hat auch genau zu diesen
augenblick gewartet aktion ist das
erhöht nochmals also ich kann ganz klar
sagen ich halte das für mich für ein
frühstück für eine cnc das frühstück was
ich morgens essen würde
das ist wirklich ein starker anfangen
gewesen und ihr habt es gesehen es war
super einfach also wirklich das 1 3
sachen die super schnell gemacht und ich
habe ich insgesamt nicht dass ich nicht
wie 30 minuten gebraucht hat woher also
wirklich alles da alles ich meine musik
mache ich jetzt und dann sehen wir uns
zum mittagessen okay leute gekommen zum
mittagessen es gibt etwas exotisches
liegt bereits meinte uns zwar wenig
russische teigtaschen ich habe bisher
kaum berührungspunkte mit der russischen
küche gehabt und habe mich
dementsprechend schlau gemacht mir
einige videos angeschaut und ist
traditionell wenig machen das sind
teigtaschen ganz ähnlich sieht ottelini
gefüllt mit kartoffeln und zwiebeln ok
aber wieder ewigkeiten okay wir haben
sind gesteht jetzt steige ich sie in
gleichgroße stücke brachten die geben
wird in einen topf brauchen wir nur für
die füllung später geben wir warum es
was wir jetzt brauchen wir sie auf der
zwischenzeit kann man willst du die
zwiebeln kartoffeln kochen mittlerweile
auch das heißt ich beziehe für die jetzt
auch
und dass die fertig werden unsere
zwiebeln chemnitz in die pfanne und die
lassen die gehälter nach gold
in der zwischenzeit fangen wir schon mal
ein hefeteig wir brauchen 500 gramm nähe
ein großes ei 200 milliliter warmes
wasser das war's wir fügen gute prise
salz hinzu und schon ein bisschen was
von dem lauwarmen wasser das erklären
wir dann das medien die schlüssel und
dann haben wir wie auch schon sein
italienische nudel treppe in die mitte
des teigs eine loch erst mal sind die
kartoffel für kartoffel haben wir jetzt
hier
jetzt würde man wenn man gut
ausgestattet wäre ein popstar benutzen
ich hab aber einfach kein wir geben
jetzt in die mitte unser ein nein und
ein bisschen laufen ist was sagt dabei
früheren arbeiten wir konstant das mädel
ist jetzt mittlerweile wie es läuft
gegen das zu meinem pasta rezept kommt
hier aber eben auch grasser zum einsatz
ist auch schon zeit nicht die hände
schmutzig zu machen das video start
abgebrochen dass er weiß nicht wie viel
noch drauf hier drunter ist auf jeden
fall der fertige teil der hat jetzt 15
minuten lang geruht ihr können jetzt
weiter bearbeiten und so einmal aus
immer schön auf die arbeitsfläche wir
machen jetzt so langsam eine rolle
daraus italienischen küche würde man
jetzt wahrscheinlich will man die pasta
maschine auspacken wollen wir schneiden
darf man einfach ein kleines stück ab
und war wenig später den recht denken ja
hier auch wieder schön mit mehr arbeiten
eine kleine rolle laufform jetzt bevor
ich hier noch groß weitermachen
mit dem teig machen wir erst mal den
film fertig dafür gehen wir einfach die
hälfte zwiebeln und geben sie zu unserem
kartoffeln quasi mit in die füllung das
können wir jetzt wieder wohnen und
arbeiten
es riecht wirklich schon richtig richtig
lecker von unserem kleinen teilchen
nehmen jetzt einfach wieder ein klein
bisschen was wir auch machen und das
wiederum kommen wir zu so einem kleinen
thaler die jetzt mit dem nudelholz
ausfall und dann gehen wir in die mitte
ein bisschen von unserer füllung dann
ganz einfach schließen wir das ganze
zelt so macht man wenig ich habe es
10.000 von den dingern gemacht und ich
gebe dir erstmal hier hinein so leute
die sind jetzt hoch gekocht wird und
jetzt geben wir die marinic die
restlichen zwiebeln ich denke mir
nochmal durch so die ersten 2000 fertig
tonini es wird zeit
ich bin ganz zufrieden
[Musik]
ich würde sagen dass es euch schmecken
neben mal die erste garde und ihr wisst
ja wir seit könnt ihr euch alle zeit der
welt lassen um auch zu spd erstmals
discounter frieden man muss ja heute die
erste gabe gegessen wir sehen uns gleich
wieder ich kann manchmal hinter euch
damit ihr wissen dass die gefahr im
nacken setzte mitbewerber auch gegessen
das erste mal dort ich dass ich russisch
gekocht habe und ich bin gespannt wie
ihr eure bewertung aus also ich war noch
mal an weil ich bin ich schon ein paar
mal war wenig gegessen aber ich glaube
hier ist der größere experte von uns
muss sagen ich schneidige nicht daraus
dass das erste mal mussten kopf nicht
einfach nur mega mega lecker und ich
möchte weiter ist geil
wir waren heute zwei erinnert werden ja
also ich muss sagen auch genau dasselbe
tun sagt weil das war noch nie gemacht
hast mir gefällt das ist wie als hättest
du das zum hundertsten mal gemacht so
effekt so kann ich gar nicht beschweren
ich habe gesagt ich soll wüsten dass ich
ihnen gesagt hat das krasseste ist egal
beim frühstück war jetzt hier
wir mussten nicht einmal nach wird
sondern hatten das gefühl es wird zu
wenig gewürzt was wären wir dafür dass
das erste mal und es ist perfekt
ich fand den teil negativ medien also
ich habe das gefühl ich könnte es auf
keinen fall besser machen ich würde
sagen einen neuen weil ich denke eine 10
müsste eine noch größere explosion vom
geschmack also wenn man ein wenig super
cool dass wir ja auch was die folge
steigern das noch nie gemacht ist also
alles was ihr nicht mitbekommen hat
hinter der klasse komplett aus in der
küche kaffee braucht das motto freu mich
richtig versah gesehen haben essen und
dann wenn ich nochmal alles geben
okay leute kommen wir auch zum
abendessen beziehungsweise um ehrlich zu
sein ist das abendessen das mittagessen
am nächsten tag das war jetzt aber zu
spät die absicht gesehen es war schon
dunkel draußen das haben wir uns gesagt
wir machen das ganze hat auch heute auch
ganz entspannt
es gibt wieder was neues ist wieder was
exotisch ist und zwar lahmacun also
türkische pizza nur dass wir das ganze
die ätherisch machen wenn man ein paar
sachen weg warst du wärst du doch vegan
aber wir machen das ganze vegetarisch
wir fangen an indem wir in unserer
altbekannte schüssel 400 gramm veganes
tag geben 300 und 4
dazu kommen zwei großzügige esslöffel
tomatenmark das ist eine swr und nur
zwei dann ein bisschen salz und pfeffer
dann so einen halben teelöffel
paprikapulver dann bleiben wir zwei
weiße und zwei rote zwiebeln zum fleisch
das ist die hölle wie die augen wollte
das passiert wenn ihr das video wir
jetzt nicht leid feierabend das ganze
gehen wir auf jeden fall jetzt auch dazu
dann gehe ich zu dem ganzen noch ein
bisschen chili pulver ein teelöffel 2 im
hintergrund hat schon mal die fahrer
aufgesetzt und dann würde ich hier noch
so zwei paprikas hinein wie gesagt rein
dürfen ganz fallen dann doch nie in
unsere schöne alternative das
wildfleisch privat wenn das freitag es
kommt auch unsere mischung so und dann
leute das hier ist ja unsere mischung
hier drinnen verlegt man das ganze
einfach mit den händen es ist eine ebene
masse ist schwächelt schon findet bei
sowas grüße omega schwer ich weiß dass
das lahmacun heißt aber ich will auch
nicht mehr so 1 3 hart klingen wird das
immer so aussprechen kann deshalb kann
es manchmal unterschiedliche aussprechen
so das ist jetzt unsere fertige mischung
beziehungsweise ist noch nicht ganz
fertig denn wir fühlen noch 60 km lieben
hinzu und die kneten mir auch einmal die
hilfe aus müller fleisch und ja ich
leute ist es auch schon soweit ich ohne
meine vorbereitet sind
denn ich mache euch das rezept für den
tiger mal in die beschreibung habe heute
schon mal ein teig gemacht dass man
jetzt nicht jedes mal zeigen
fangen wir an dem tag aus zu wollen ein
esslöffel nehmen uns was von unserer
fleisch pasta oder eben nicht vielleicht
passte und verteilen das ganze noch
erledigt ist kann das gute stück auch
noch unsere pizza mix natürlich gewählt
wird ja es ist der erste und den wert
auf dem peter stein so ich hab mir den
grill mit dem pizza stein vorgeheizt und
gehen wir jetzt den lama schon drauf
hoffe ich zumindest dass ich irgendwie
hinbekommen
das wird meine diesem petent rotation in
den nächsten ich bin diesmal ich ein
bisschen vorsichtiger und wollte nicht
so krass aus den ersten streichen
[Musik]
der gut der wird sehr gut sagt ich
glaube ja doch der ist gut
ich belege direkt den ersten döner
fleisch dönerfleisch natürlich noch dick
zur cdu über
die sache ist wahrscheinlich schwer dass
das zusammenhält weil normalerweise ist
das ja so in alufolie aber ist
eigentlich für die verschwendung oder ja
das ist derzeit nicht der erste ist
fertig zumindest der erste halbwegs
stimmen hier ist der wirklichkeit erst
werde dann lass dir schnell kapital aus
ok viele geschmacks reaktion die ich bin
wirklich sehr gespannt wie oder sind
schon geil aus das ding jetzt ich muss
sagen seitdem ich mich vegetarisch
ernähren vermisse ich so ein bisschen
lammert
deswegen freue ich mich immer sehr wenn
man irgendwo meine möglichkeiten
vegetarischen lamatsch zu bekommen
[Musik]
damit war die ganze zeit weiter lahmacun
gemacht und währenddessen wurde hier
drüben schon heiß diskutiert wir sagen
ebenso im kreis ich sehr gern süßes
ich habe so viel ist das erste mal das
gemacht hat was sagt ja also also
jedenfalls sehr gut geschmeckt das kann
man das war wirklich sehr weißt doch
selbst auf der ich würd ich bin jetzt
nicht der experte dafür aber zwar sehr
gut aber ich hatte sogar mal 1 1 davon
waren das wo ich gesagt wo ich das
gefühl hatte dass die konsistenz von der
soße und dem teig oder noch besser ist
safe ich glaube nämlich das was was noch
besser sein können ist dass dies die
soße irgendwie gefühlt noch mehr an dem
tag steckt und nicht das wenn man drauf
weiß dass diese sich sonst noch so viel
verteilt also dieses letzte große titel
passte und vielleicht ein bisschen zu
viel mehl außerhalb
ich habe auch die will ich haben das
wirtschafts ab zu machen aber ich hatte
angst dass es wieder mehr alles klar
das system bleibt deswegen wir wollten
dir gründe nennen warum wir den nicht
volle punktzahl geben und zwar haben wir
gedacht wir geben dir 85 punkte und
villach mit
das war wirklich super lecker das
minimale kleinigkeiten das muss man sich
mal vor augen führen also war wenig hier
sind von der komplexität relativ
überschaubarem 12 für den hier hast du
100 sachen die zusammen kommt deshalb
bin ich mega zufrieden mein job ich bin
eine sache nämlich auch ganz kurz dazu
sagen weil das ist vielleicht so leicht
gesagt 815 ich persönlich würde das
nicht so gut hinbekommen du kannst du
das wirklich richtig gut was ein
händchen dafür dankeschön leute das war
wirklich eine mega ich finde auch
persönlich eine besondere folge wir
haben neue sachen gelernt weil ich cool
hat spaß gemacht mit euch und wir sehen
uns nächsten sonntag wieder 14 uhr
wir wissen bescheid und lasten da leute
und danach
[Musik]